[music]
now the dream of hot
infections starts as support unit speak you
really great and use and actually it's
the first time
somewhere conference sticks my team
starts looking forward to set
conference and many interesting
discussions
so people dream is a cummings
von seehofers that  heidi insofar as one
is out of the position ist research
organizations missing
some of inventions be made you made in
africa for example
mp3 format
all
things like a difficult to watch the
first resources and actually an institute
ist group christi fischl intelligence
we have more than three  hundred
researchers at 4 takt inside business
for more than twenty years in our
clients and research partners came from
start ups too big ducks
companies and
[music]
artificial intelligence
members of many that is in germany but
institute director s cut off the expert
group from the  european
university cooperation with the office
for information security es concrete
people ak  tiv in the addition
of today is to hold and solarworld like
to share some other supporters
group in assessment of artificial
intelligence review
tequila also like to present and
assessment catalog that has been
published by that allows you to a
trustworthy
functions and
technology preview of the  project
services kaindorf
equivalent of confusion sales to
introduce you to develop standards and
assessment
and exciting times for artificial
intelligence
and service of leading
die consulting company is the company is
now entering scaling face for artificial
intelligence
living surface of proof of concepts and
artificial artificial intelligence is
really the bankruptcy in real life systems
and sales service salt company south
struggle to be successful heart
of the trees and first difficult to
switch
systems and important to have to have to
quality standard to the
shoah
compliance standards would like to first
race for artificial intelligence and
have  been publ  ished
novel
expert group european junior publish
guidelines trustworthy use of artificial
intelligence and escape
to
implement
concrete systems and actually also skin
since
then compliance
guidelines
place
because in germany has been
standardization roadmap for artificial
intelligence
results have been published
lasten im dezember roadmap is then different things  first
of all the view of standards and
important for artificial intelligence in
the plan of the related lot sanchez safety
security software development of
standards and ride systems and needs to
be taken to
developing
systems turn about half solist despite solist the state of
the art of
standards
city warns of standards and to be the w
rld whether this question of quality and a
tually care [musi
] syste
s an compliance quality is a very impor
ant questions to the state and resul
s show basic
lly two things first of testi
g framework guara
tees compa
ibility tests
existence systems.com price at  the same time
process testing and order
rogers in olso product related disorders
stock market
metrics and fresh and can be bankrupt
two different use cases
european june in hesse publisher
relations proposal for artificial
intelligence
[music]
data systems particular imports service
systems basically everything witches
safety security critics  all things like
scoring system smith financial service
industry
fired up this
systems
that you get a compliant t
systems play is our brand
documentation
conformity
company in america
don't have to tackle
question about privacy and peter
a very old as well as
you industries quality standards  and
competitive advantage
of the quality assessment basically you can
build you candy white motivations to
building blocks so wandered builds
internal trust quality assessment can
help you to convince internal paypal the
system is for example develop the world
company be on short question of
building external t  rust you have a
space plant science of important for
customers
to be in the context and if fine the
you can all things like a service trends
offset quality assessment is
base for example of
insurance
and where you can with
responding insurance as you have it for
example old are so field of cyber
security which is a bit of the
development of artificial intelligence
the next live shows have roger's
topic evaluation and assessment of
systems
and just people sets the
station roadmap
of the publisher december
[music]
process organization
guidelines
for example
is the question  of trust
organizational concept based on management
systems management systems
battle to fund concept for massa domains
as well as have for example
information security management system
systems its
2010 half
quality management system around 1,000
series and we have just finished the
study and fraunhofer sit interest status
of the country being developed and
management  system  tem for artificial
intelligence and we have complete is
standard where it you
once married expert group
on
sea cloud catalog company vettel office
for information security
catalog set
addresses cloud based services
appalled because the as to be published in the
october
management system in olso the comparison
you can  of course as a witch perspective
of
systems and how two as it works
of systems and here
we have to
most important
coming understanding is the june
contract
both lifecycle on the
rating
systems all you have to start fair
design face when they have this is about
this is
implemented by design says privacy by
design also very viability bydesign
attached development face for you have
to take a look into the data base
questions like it is the training
day
[music]
operational design domain
general data quality if josef
questions about you
composers
platform for the  purpose of system i
have something bridges sometimes please
an estimated  embedded component into the
office system because you
systems hybrid systems as intelligent
as here comes firma intelligent
combination of death and
techniques and the classical software
components
sometimes classical software components
a critical path of the safe garding
offset system for example classical
software asset supervisors sensor
contains them
is essential stroke units at the
start of backpackers that one very much
now so very important to take a look
into the
models patolsky
embedding from the wood system then when
we are on course to quests to pause
operations deployment of
development publish dustin julie is an
assessment catalog supporters  systematic
assessment of resistance level 1 just
what you so long life cycle of system
one hundred 6 pages documents its
state of the art
get your view our procedure so
forester
woman both
teams are us carrier ssb college and
risk areas
sunrise in the hotel know potentially functioning
she's d  ifferent the human sex
traffic light before so
many animals like have a question of
reliability
operation so since the dresses questions
for example classification auguste
classification in terms of classical kps
think first question of the busters the
system davis my neusorg changes to
the incoming data
is to be  expected that his nation
strategies the system the
red state of the art of operational
design dld to halberstadt is
the
estimate of uncertainty and finally
hits the cracks dynamics of the system at
home the model meets a concept
first of all the helpers
top down the
project  space immediately vivantes is usa
trustworthy
function of course race with regard to
the specific
operational context
we need to do that with respect to
important dimensions of the association
transparency and
the first avenger case is what we call
it actually it's analysis of the first
estimation of the people  important
in the 4 4 example image
based quality control  must have the
trio context
installed cristiano
dating percent if it is nottwil
risk and does not need to be consistent is
different than
the people is a port and you have
to do
concrete risk analysis with regard to the
extent to define tags describe this
date on which  this is officially we'll
meet again
the next steps to define
metrics case that make
that make it mashable sees days
zb reach standard as well as broken booklet down
the question a question
is trustworthy zuse question better she
is criteria mashable at metrics
report
to build safety  safe guarding
argumentation and here now
important to take a look at the show
with regard to the data
a tourist meter in the exhibition center
you the criteria
zb risk analysis in the previous
sap user can then you can't you sexy
eva chen is safeguard respect of
carriers
can build
safeguard arguing against them from
wrong prescriptions
is
frosta people assessment because you
have conflict  between different
tags random sampl if you're gone to
increase of system
security systems and i'm off to increase
transparency of system unite usf
possibility
factors and you might have a conflict
between transparency and security also
transparency
of intellectual property
is our enemies is
different  it is christa people
assessment
pea on the catalog is the
documentation of the prodigy be
careful use
cases documentation and for hiking time
can surf and documentation it will soon be
in articles
regulation apple spokesman european
junior also recognize surfaces of
independent assessment
corresponding
motto of
an always la concept has  been
developed by the sword project gold
no protection will present the
project between days later on the job
and
no protection is project lead the
german automotive industry
way to develop to develop safe garding
argumentations
fashion models autonomous driving and
we have in part this success  is
safety a  rgumentations
so our eleven dancers
kenzo lifecycle specification on
you because you can't do ass systematic
investigation of potential
members and safe the rangers on open
ears network and you can
the bankruptcy of manchester city
safety
critical limb south central networks
east majors clear way despite
insolvency  by means of example
the ground
context you can do some testing system
develops the testing on
441 plaster baseballs
monitoring system you can to or
uncertainties and
active data
protection appliance
case
metrics in order to
quality
officers and two
president of fire safety
argumentation ford motor enthusiasts
ex  mtv
news case
paper chance offered by my colleague
michael mock and
others have
[music]
proven in
advance
if you can of course of the question
on 9 safety critical systems one
assessment of systems is he asks easy
example
falls one already here is medium sized
enterprises  in germany
based services company is an ext  rakt
information from technical training
center saint pennt
our change and you our
system is reliable and set
information extraction happens must
use reliability ice example of some cases more
company is
developing the best practice and also
need of quality
specifications
quality seals viewers to very
customers
conceptual
percent  so
built
documentation of the user and trust
version is on course just love
story and of course you always on tools
in order to evaluate
quality properties of systems in which
initially
drive to make it like to give brief
overview
household chairs
what we actually
not on the example säntis  grades complete
overview was the sphinx
imports topic
developer tools
reason why we need aus tools is on
course whether we do it so
basically im possible for human
ssd north taste quality
systems
ways to the
classical software and go away
question of respect test coverage of
the question  that hasn't ss can
und  she bought
1x traffic light would like to show overview of
certain quality tools and have been
developed to evaluate the fence off
system as well as help and care in the lot
about fairness in the box office
for systems and i played with the
financial services industry for example
is important and i  have we have open
source solution provider at ibm also
306 ps distant tools tools and provided
by private jet there are the state from so
very high bunch of office tools of
global and in neuruppin with imports
question is important questions how to
how to judge the tools  and know how to
make these tools interoperable
the purchase sum left tools addressed
aspects of the system
for different aspects ionita rented
culture
sense second example would like to show
off topic of
reasons
in the
test data and where you cannot quality
of audio us cars they help
you
So does it hold campus more information
you can use
are tenants data center day
two for example
systematic search training there  y
correlation operated
missions miss sunshine of your networks
and certain situation
when you finished sample is related
to this one is visual analytics tool
systematic ali
investigate
test data set
peter seitz and general in olso
information about comics on new
networks and old to
make the puzzle  scouting system label
improved security
in the last
of me your car would like to the beat
and talk about
the project certified rtos certified
an english no hit
similar project
is coming like
the project is actually starting justin
eickelmann partners
fraunhofer german federal office for
information security
for very much  engaged in creating
notifications teams because so german
institute for standardization
die
research and research partners
eisl friends extreme project
testing principles of development area
different website testing and concept
for
testing and assessment infrastructure
because we have the second
dresses different business mo  dels and
associated with
the quality assessment of artificial
intelligence
then at business partners coming companies
academy
when the helpers jörg piller
concrete use cases coming from the
associated partners and develop testing
and assessment quarters
tests against use cases either as
associated partners in the industrial and
mids
user  before players also
heil important
questions of developing assessment tools
ecosystem to maxis testing and
assessment tools interoperable
finally have side of the people very
long research partners and coming this
coming from long set a coming from fx
and social sciences in series to
public events to inform the construction time
imports topic 1 ff
er loud on industrial
partner page partners and project
came from different industries to the
value
opportunity to get inside and defend
dietz from defense industries
and like to
move it move title of different you
might partner john feldmann office for
information security is very much
group size question of thirty fiction
an basic lisa have to process that the
following the
life cycle ea boss also
published is her
ex-husband catalog
cloud based services in the second life
action the address certification of
congress systems and you have the
product interfaces
related perspective
if a person is
project k hedging
project
project hedging 1 project is
many partners for the
automotive industry
in germany internet at volkswagen and
fraunhofer end of the partner can
director automotive
industry vaa dolls
company is like my kind of the board
director automotive
silent before imports components  for
automatically driving the project is ready
to use the
developing safe garding argumentations
in this context on autonomous strips
we have the german institute for
standardization
just publish roadmap
last let your
roadmap
foundation for artificial intelligence
like the nation need for example
classifications by taminelli
ter  minology
its we had horizons topix like fx you
question of quality assessment of
artificial intelligence
solid framework along the working
groups
it sony
trans pacific vertical sectors
industry mobility and
results of the
road map have been published let you
very proud update to be prepared an
update multi  development
published
its em
you
[music]
our project certified
activities of different partners
project
in the endnote question what
we do and what we do in germany award
wie du in italy the
important questions house
questions and can be
european travel expo also
legal framework that  is
looking forward to the discussion
our potential of the
corporate
translation project
[applause]
so
[music]
discreetly use cases like for example
automotive industry very very proud lot
of work
then turn into the project
use cases financial services industry
[music]
chemical industry
starts in
work and travel
our technical perspective
perspective from the
dutchman from the film society
the algorithms
properties the yuan
tourism pacific new
question is the first ever strapped
to something since the
professional specification since the duw
example welcome quartier via
framework that have it security
features and
interesting
information security
don't have to
love cost  research just wanted to
point out for
educational
complex
[music]
patrick saile use case dependence die
pensen our use case and you
contexts use cases applied also an
sie messechef used to realize artificial
intelligence and future store built
fairness ser/2
different metrics to measure group
fairness sesam more concept to call
center individual fellner so wand
youtube comparison user groups against
the one time to compare individuals
adds the damage point activated on
flexing publish the suburb of rotterdam
people
together is and questions for
standardization to make the trustees
metrics and maybe makers and  action
which the track is prepared for that use
case if even more difficult question
is
fresh as a
private individual be diligent and rector certain
use cases thing now together extender
question for standardization left afterwards
the station costs now getting to
comply chains at the
moment like have to
reason  why i dig the track data quality
massa metrics traffic light is red
sets so
addressed with assessment
center in translation is
from the institute only the
second presentation
there is practically
no
active forms
this
practice
then so
attractive
property but people from the
bed has the
students  do you know my problem also
put imports question that question
answer to some extent that west wise
station roadmaps
overview and different technology sandwich
context
the
industry
[music]
compliment
together is
project i think
you can learn
money transfer process from changing the
domain
technology safe guarding concept  from
automotive approx  n be played
industrial use cases for example the
same time in epping set very
kruschel question we have industries
pacific
relations and assessment framework
already today and
institutions
of example in germany we have the bafin
supervisors financial services industry
different fortis self supervisor
industries and of course  we have
establish standards
are so field of safety security all
these field of financial services with
models used by financial service
industries are
made and which may not be used in
certain contact
one very important
to private solution for you better be
it until
the playoffs  xss men concepts
holzartikel intelligence
[music]
corresponding domains
same time to make sure that is different
computer technician levels
industry specific requirements of
questions about the technical
computer
complete
[music]
this
almost
importen topic
basic georg
different countries of public strategies
defence  of time job can
cost can the complete picture
gerold a lot of activities
international mci so she is changes
group management systems people
presentation
international mci
activities
[music]
word of god
practical chief technical standards for
artificial intelligence
worldwide a if we also have a
question south
african society guard world and this
probably more difficult alone and the
international level set 21 finks
important to make a difference operated
technician questions about at fish
intelligence and questions on the one to
use as
often
[music]
700 system
and had the prominent
to luginger  repression user social
networks of trust and maybe important
for
project i have one
controller
question aufhausen
user ins system is distributed to also
rich information
for systemic the private user north to
to enable
questions of users and the city
[music]
the things
and
technical aspects of
usability
question of
qual  ity statements that can be made of
quality statements that are maybe not
fischl certification
dress should use service packs on the
systems kelly
preston is ramzi
[music]
partner academy
investigating the things that question
for example which of the people
shook
tcf in order to
create trust
for  use of
medicine you think you think maximilian
[applause]